in 2004 Mean Girls became an instant
cultural Touchstone with quotable lines
and star making performances from Rachel
McAdams and Lindsay Lan in 2024 a new
Mean Girls has emerged and fans seem
less than enthused to put it mildly oh
hell no it would appear a major source
of contention comes down to people not
realizing the new movie is in fact a
musical the original hit film was
adapted into a musical that ran on
Broadway and it's that adaptation that's
now available in theaters unfortunately
a lot of people on X formerly known as
Twitter seem to be outright hostile
toward musical numbers one person
tweeted mean girl sucks it was a musical
and I hate musicals they weren't alone
in that assessment as plenty of other
ex-users hated having to listen to songs
one wrote The Mean Girls movie is
terrible and I hate the songs they don't
fit at all these reactions seem to be a
prime example of why studios are
hesitant to Market films like Wonka And
Mean Girls as musicals in the first
place and there's no shortage of Mean
Girls hate online from people not real
realizing the new movie as a musical and
that's resulted in another common type
of post from people who are dumbfounded
people don't do their research before
going to see something one user is
curious about whether the added
attention could benefit the movie
writing I'm loving all the Tik toks of
people not realizing it was a musical
that kind of marketing will either hurt
it or help it others called out all the
Mean Girls haters far more directly one
user posted multiple clips from the
trailers showcasing intricate dance
choreography and character singing They
further commented with a screenshot of
what you see when Googling the movie and
Mean Girls is classified as a
comedy/musical even if audiences were
unaware that mean girls had a Broadway
adaptation easy access to the internet
means there's an endless supply of
information at most people's fingertips
and one ex user thinks this whole thing
says more about the general public than
the movie itself listen Mean Girls and
all musical films should be advertised
as musicals but I've worked in the
ticketing industry long enough to not
feel an ounce of sympathy for someone
who gets mad about the ticket they
bought without doing an ounce of
research on what they were buying chalk
this up as another case study of how
people are somehow less informed in the
digital age than ever before but maybe
it'll be good in the long run for people
to do their research before spending
money on a movie ticket what is going
on don't worry about it and for many
people it's a bit disappointing to see
so many people completely discount
something due to its genre musicals have
a rich history and in a certain regard
it's nice that mean girls isn't simply a
complete retread of the original and to
be fair plenty of people online were
fine with 24's Mean Girls some
criticisms were about how the movie
doesn't live up to the Musical one user
compared the stage and film versions of
the song someone gets hurt and preferred
the Broadway interpretation then there
are those who unabashedly love Mean
Girls One user sang the movie's Praises
writing Mean Girls 2024 is endlessly
entertaining and just a really good time
lots of creative cinematography
Direction going on as it shifts in and
out of musical sequences Loopers Audrey
Fox was lukewarm on the movie as a whole
but even admitted the songs helped
Elevate the production Mean Girls is at
its most fun when it lets itself be a
full-on musical rather than a
reenactment of the greatest hits from
the original film the online discourse
surrounding 2024's Mean Girls is
fascinating for all the questions it
raises why do so many people in this day
and age hate musicals do people really
see movies without understanding what
they are and will movie studios ever
Market a musical as a musical
again